Angell Tiger is a speaker and activist
and an entrepreneur she works with the
LA cannabis medical task force and runs
her own cannabis edibles company known
as Ruby doobie and we've got a lot of
Ruby dooby goodies in front of us right
now
angel thanks for thanks for joining me
thank you for inviting me Dave
yeah I'm very excited to talk to you
because I've wanted to do something a
little more in-depth on pot for a long
time and and you brought pot cookies
brownies let's get into this stuff first
okay and then we'll talk about the
history at legalization what do we got
in front of us these are some of the
things that I make
sweet dreams brownie it's a dusted with
a little bit of sea salt on top it's
about 57 milligrams
here so 37 milligrams of THC what does
that mean so you you ate that how do you
feel after well I personally would not
eat a whole brownie right I would have
half and that's plenty for me but it
really depends on your own metabolism
and your your how experienced you are
and it can differ on depending on the
day and on how much you've eaten that
day right and doshas dosage guidelines
very you know I've seen recommended
dosages between 5 and 15 milligrams for
people or some who want between 20 and
30 and this is all sort of unchartered
territory for a lot of people because
for a long time you know I think I said
once on the show when I got my weed card
I went in there and I said you know they
showed me wax they showed me oil they
showed me edibles I said well do you
have any just weed you know green buds
like old fashioned weed and that made me
feel like old I got a guy wants a smoked
weed but this is sort of the new thing
right
well you I think not as many people are
familiar with edibles but it's been
around and it's a great way to make use
of the whole plant because really what
when you smoke you're smoking the
flowers the buds mmm
but you still have all of the leaves and
the trim and the small buds and all of
that has a
you know active ingredients in it too
and that's primarily what I used to make
my goodies and here's a peanut butter
brownie ginger cookie the crew is very
excited by the way I'm happy
ginger cookies credible cookies and
chocolate chip cookies and I make cakes
and other things too lemon bars yeah so
you make all this stuff and this is for
people that may want the medicinal
benefits this is for people that may
want the recreational benefits it
doesn't matter to you right like you're
selling it then and yeah it's nice of
someone alleviates some pain but right
well I work with the dispensaries I work
with a handful of dispensaries in my
area so I am a member that's that's
providing edibles for my fellow members
sure and you know you can't really you
you can't in California you still have
to get a doctor's recommendation to even
go to those dispensaries right so my
sacha hard it's not it isn't right and
and it's tough to make the distinction
between what's recreative to distinguish
between recreational and medicinal
because if it's if you're using it to
relax at the end of the day and to
de-stress hmm that's me that's it isn't
it in some ways yeah all right so let's
get a little bit into your story and
then we'll talk about business and
legalization and all that chef so you
got into weed basically I think you were
smoking it recreationally but the reason
you really got into this was because you
were having migraines and pretty much
the Western medicine that you were
trying just wasn't anything right yes
but I think there were two forces that
kind of both intersected and and drove
me into cannabis
definitely my migraines I I've had
migraines for many many years and about
ten years ago they started getting a lot
worse and more frequent and I was trying
all kinds of different medications
I had a steroids injected into my neck
to try to get rid of them I had some
prescriptions
that were so strong that they require
that the triplicate prescription you
know and nothing helped me I mean lots
of times that the drugs would irritate
my stomach so much that I would feel
worse sometimes they would just knock me
out and that's how I was survived my
migraines no and cannabis is really what
allowed me to to continue living and
manage them without having to check out
for weeks at a time or days at a time so
that definitely treating my migraines
was one forest and also a desire to
simplify my life you know I am I was
working at the XPrize Foundation I was a
chief of staff there and you know very
rewarding challenging position but I
just felt that there was something
missing you know I I wasn't spending
very much time with my son who was two
years old at the time I would have to
travel a lot and I just wanted to create
a change in my life where where I would
not be so dependent on on a check grow
growth my own food and cook my own meals
and and rather than pay someone to do
this and that I wanted to do those
things I wanted to be the one with with
my family right so that's really
interesting so it wasn't just I want to
get stoned and have a good time you got
into the edible garden thing which it
was nice you were growing weed but you
were also growing stuff to actually eat
and to lead to feed your child we were
growing in at one point we were going
enough food in our garden that it was
too much for us to even eat I mean
neighbors would come and we encouraged
our neighbors to come and tomatoes
artichokes peppers eggplants collard
greens
charred kale I mean we still have you
know lemon trees apple trees nectarines
oranges it's a beautiful thing to just
go outside and pick your food and you
know you don't have to get in your car
yeah yes you can't get anything fresher
than that yeah it's funny I have I mean
I live in LA - and you know I have a
little outdoor space with a little
garden and even if I'm just plucking
tomatoes or something I find that very
therapeutic oh it is so just that action
of doing of growing something for
yourself whether it's marijuana or a
tomato or a pepper or something even
right there connecting with nature this
is all intertwined with ultimately you
going into this business I believe so I
mean it's wanting to simplify wanting to
be more in touch with nature you know
it's so easy to get disconnected from
food and to know what food looks like
when it's actually growing I mean when I
when we first planted our garden it was
with the help of a nonprofit called la
green grounds and we had 50 volunteers
come out and help us plant our front
yard and our parkways and I was
intimidated because I had never tried to
grow food before and I didn't know how
it all worked and it's I'd never put my
hands in the dirt and planted anything
and to watch things grow and to be able
to feed my family that way and and help
you know feed the neighborhood it was an
amazing experience and food food is
medicine
you know cannabis is medicine I mean I
really don't see much of a difference
right so you see this green thing that
grows naturally from the earth like all
this other stuff that we eat you see
that just sort of as an extension of
every other thing but the city wasn't
that thrilled right with your your
garden so here you are a person that
sort of takes life into your own hands
on your own property and the city of Los
Angeles what did they do
well okay going back a little while I
what got me inspired to plant the garden
as I watched a TED talk
by Ron Finley I don't know if you've
heard of him the gorillas garden against
gangster garden oh okay yeah so um the
whole idea of that he presented growing
your own food is like printing your own
money I mean there were some things that
just resonated so deeply with me that
immediately after I saw the talk I I got
in touch with la green grounds and said
I I need to learn how to do this how can
I volunteer and it turns out they were
actually looking for an LA resident to
plant a garden and the timing was
perfect so we planted we were selected
and that's how we got our garden so yeah
the city though didn't want you to do it
it's something all right so Ron when he
when he did his TED talk he had planted
an edible garden a few years before mine
and was sighted and went to City Council
and made the case that you know it
doesn't make sense you should allow
people to grow food on their on their
parkways and the City Council at that
time agreed and said that they would
work to change the laws in fast forward
two years later I plant you know we
plant our garden
and I was operating under the assumption
that it was all good right the the
changes were in the works but a few
months after this we were cited I mean a
guy came to my house and kind of
aggressively said you know all of this
has to come out and you have 48 hours to
put it all back to the way it was and so
this had nothing to do with weed just to
me know this is known squash yeah oh yes
eggplants oh yeah things like that so
that because we had the support of a lot
of you know la green grounds and Ron and
it was easy to to get attention drawn to
the to the issue it had been going on
for some time
Lopez from the LA Times came out and and
wrote an article about our garden and it
it helped bring the City Council's
attention back to this issue and not
long after that they did change the laws
so you anyone in LA can can grow fruits
and vegetables on their on their Parkway
before you had to there was only a short
list of approved things you could grow
right and if you wanted to deviate from
that you had to I think
filed a request and I think was like
$400 to even ask just to ask to use your
own property yeah your own yeah and then
you know you might not get the approval
yeah so now I think the way the law
reads is you can grow whatever you want
except for some some fruit trees are not
allowed to be on the Parkway but it was
it's a huge step right right now as long
as you have a medical marijuana license
you can also grow eat I'm guessing you
can't do that in the front of your house
though I don't think it was it would be
such a good idea probably not a great
idea all right well I don't want to get
too into the weeds on that one antenna
but I thought it was an interesting way
to start because it shows how marijuana
and legalization and medicinal uses and
all that are so tied into our legal
system and then we can get into some of
that stuff so alright so you have the
migraines you start saying all right I'm
going to smoke weed to make myself feel
better how long did it take to figure
out what worked for you what actually
was the right strain and can you talk
about strains a little bit well you know
I I know with some conditions people
look for particular strains you know I
think okay so there there yeah let's do
let's do one away yeah when you talk
about cannabis there there's cannabis
indica and sativa right I sit there
they look different physically like
sativa plants are usually taller and
leaner thinner branches and grow better
in warmer climates
kazar kind of shorter and bushier and
hard ear
besides that indicas are usually they
help to relax you most people will use
them at night too as a sleep aid or and
sativas generally will give you more
energy let you keep more focus so more
people will use sativas during the day
because you can still function all my
comedian friends that get stoned on
sativas and write all day yeah exactly
right and then within okay so you have
strains that are either indica or sativa
or they can be a hybrid and then each
particular strain has its own profile
how much THC is in there how much CBD is
in there yeah and so let's unpack that a
little bit so THC is the psychoactive
are correct and CBD is is it's the
medicinal part is there to describe that
THC also has medicinal properties but it
is the psychoactive a element CBD is is
cannabidiol it's another cannabinoid
those aren't the only two I mean there
there are others and but CBD does seem
to have most of the medicinal value I
mean it can it can it's been shown to
stop some tumor growth it's you know
it's great for pain relief its reduces
inflammation you know it's I mean I have
a friend that takes CBD well for anxiety
right and she told me all she does
literally is it she's a little dropper
in the morning she drops like two drops
of every time that's it
it doesn't have the diarrhea and
vomiting and thoughts of suicide and
restless leg syndrome and all the other
crazy things that come with all the
commercials that you see on TV for all
these other antidepressant
it's it's there it's so gentle I mean it
has so many benefits and has never
killed anyone
um mentioned that at the top I've never
murdered in yeah yet to happen but it's
it still boggles my mind that a plant
first of all that has so many medicinal
properties so and besides medicine I
mean what about you know renewable
energy and you know paper you know I
mean it's it's strong it's a strong
fiber I mean replace so many things the
fact that we look at it is such an evil
thing I don't understand
yeah how can I can tell it it truly
boggles the mind
yes yeah yes all right so we have THC
CBD and then you have the indica and
sativa and the hybrids of that so for
the medicinal stuff let's just do that
first people if you didn't want to get
stoned but you just wanted medicinal
benefits that's where you would use just
the CBD is that right um okay CBD yes
you you want that but there's been a lot
of research research that shows that CBD
alone is not as effective as when you
mix it with THC meaning that it's the
whole plant that you want to treat you
with not just taking a one piece of it
um I think it it's referred to as the
entourage effect because there's so many
elements and they all kind of work
together so people who are looking for
CBD are usually looking for CBD rich
strains or in some cases you know like
the concentrates and things like that
but I think for the most part you'll
find that they're more effective when
when there is a little THC in there yeah
so when you found the right one for you
well first up how long did it take for
you to find
weed that was like oh these migraines
are dying you know I didn't even think
about weed as a treatment for my
migraines because when I get bad
migraines I would get very nauseous
dizzy a smoking pot was the last thing I
thought would help me really but then I
I did read that it helps and for me it's
it it relaxes me enough that I mean it
it helps the nausea and also it helps me
control the anxiety that comes along
with with the onset of a migraine I
don't know if it's like two things
attacking you at once
if the migraine but then knowing it's
coming now you're said oh my gosh about
that yes and the need to try to hit both
it treats both of those things yeah yeah
yeah um all right so then you started
doing that it was working when did you
say all right I could make a business
out of this or I got it I gotta tell
people what's going on here well you
know a friend of mine was baking and I
was fascinated by it and so I would look
up recipes and send them to me you
should try this you should try that and
he's finally he got to the point where
he said you know what angel you should
try it so I started experimenting and
that's how I got introduced to making
edibles and then I started trying them
because well honestly I tried a few
edibles and hated them I mean this is
going back to like 2008 or something I
mean before they had perfected right the
brownies in the cook exactly I mean at
that time you'd go to a dispensary and
you'd see stuff that was just in like
Ziploc bags and you know totally
unappetizing to look at and oftentimes
didn't taste very good and I mean I
found myself in those early days just
sort of like you know eating it real
quick and just
hoping for the best when now it's like
literally it's like going into a great
Baker oh you can get any anything pizzas
sauces so chocolate bars can be any I
can think of yeah
you